[Música]
[Aplausos]
a mil 16 años conocí a matías el amor de
mi vida
a su lado me sentía la persona más feliz
del mundo
me sentía amada protegida
un 24 de abril para el día de mi
cumpleaños me dice es un test de
embarazo en la casa de mi mamá el que me
había dado positivo
sin que nadie me viera salí y me fui a
la librería que estaba cerca de mi casa
y me compré un cuaderno
en este cuaderno había pensado en
escribir todas las cosas lindas que debe
sentir una mujer cuando está embarazada
desde las pataditas los antojos o cuando
se te va transformando el cuerpo crecen
las estrías o cuando sentís por primera
vez el latido del corazón de tu bebé
pero a pasar el tiempo empecé a escribir
otras cosas como las patadas los
empujones situaciones que pasaba
cotidianamente con matías
con ya de 7 meses de embarazo me había
anotado a una escuela nocturna
que para llegar a la escuela debía
cruzar todo el descampado
un día yendo a la escuela
ya lleva a mientras el descampado
siento
y alguien venía detrás mío
me di vuelta y lo vi a matías
ese día habíamos pelea
y me decía de qué
quería que me quedara con él
y lo perdonará
yo le dije que no quería irme a estudiar
así que seguí caminando
cuando voy caminando siento un ruido
como que si algo se había caído
cuando me di vuelta
lo veo
a matías
y dado en el piso
acercándose con un cable
no quería estar ahí
así que apriete fuerte mi cuadernos
y seguí caminando
y de salir lo más rápido posible hay
cuando voy caminando
luego siento paso que corrían detrás mío
no alcancé a darme vuelta
qué matía
puso sus dos manos sobre mi cuello y
empezó a el carmen
no podía respirar
mi panza se había puesto muy duro
intenté pedir ayuda muchas veces pero
nadie me escuchó
y cuándo
por fin suelto
mi cuello
caía rodilla del piso
como he visto que hablando muy mal de mí
dijeron que era culpable de todo lo que
viví tuve que caminar con mi cabeza
gacha dejando que yo abran una herida
que mi alma como puede ser que no me
podía reír como puede ser que no me
podía vestir como una bella dama me
quería de luz y si te golpea es tu culpa
atiende lo mejor si te grita es por algo
no lo haga renegar si te toma de la
fuerza intentos de escapar estoy harta
de la gente que no ve la realidad que la
violencia es algo grave quema de la
sociedad hasta que sus oídos porque está
la verdad somos asesinadas golpeadas y
maltratadas no escuchan nuestro grito
cuando pedimos ayuda después ya es muy
tarde nos comen los gusanos saben lo
difícil que es asumir que somos
cualquiera si queremos salir se llenan
la boca hay pobre mujer pero nadie hizo
nada cuando ella habló los ojos ya
hinchados de tanto llorar mare la
almohada traga en el dolor de un grito
callado que nadie escuchó cuando
aquellas noches es sueño perdió se mira
al espejo su rostro cambió algo les
faltaba su luz y apagó el paso del
tiempo se le reflejó su voz
aquí ya que parece dolor barquitos de
papel nada van en la almohada
yo agobiado pero igual siempre con ganas
no aflojaba él luchaba todos los días
esta es mi historia te la cantó con
poesía
3 a 0
la música salva la vida
porque través de ellas puede empezar a
contar lo que me estaba pasando se
transformó en mi refugio un lugar donde
me sentía fuerte donde me sentía libre
donde podría ser yo mismo
yo desde niña solía escribir en millares
íntimos porque tenían terror de
olvidarme de las cosas pero cuando
conocí la música fue realmente diferente
ella hizo que las palabras ocultas y
silenciadas que estaban entre las hojas
de mis cuadernos volarán por el universo
entero
ya hace un tiempo que con una de mis
hermanas cantábamos en una banda de rap
y un día en un show cantando una canción
que habíamos compuesto contando la
situación de violencia que estábamos
atravesando desde el escenario a una
mujer que estaba llorando
cuando terminamos de cantar esa mujer se
nos acercó y nos abrazo
sin conocer nos empezó a contarnos que
yo también estaba pasando por
situaciones de violencia y que agradecía
de ver a mujeres como nosotras que se
animaban a contar ya no callar que le
dábamos una esperanza para seguir
luchando
ese día me hizo un tremendo clic en la
cabeza porque empecé a tener conciencia
de lo importante que era poder hablar y
ser escuchada
porque eso a mí me permitió conocer a
muchas otras personas que me acompañaron
que me apoyaron que me guiaron que me
escucharon y que estuvieron conmigo
siempre los momentos más duros y que aún
no siguen estando
entonces
en mi barrio yo vivo la zona sureste de
córdoba no había un lugar donde las
mujeres de mi barrio pudiéramos
encontrarnos no habló de la manera
típico de lo que hacemos en el barrio
que por ejemplo cuando vamos al
dispensario a hacer la fila para gastar
con un turno no hablo de otra manera
encontrarnos otra forma diferente en
donde pudiéramos compartir nuestras
experiencias saberes donde nos
pudiéramos divertir con las mujeres
donde pudiéramos hacer cosas lindas
donde él pudiéramos ananos y
transformarnos conjuntamente entonces
con mi hermana y unas compañeras y
amigas decidimos hacer algo
y lo que hicimos fue armar una
organización de mujeres que se llama
mujeres activando en el cual trabajamos
la prevención de la violencia de género
a través del arte y de la cultura damos
talleres de poesía música fotografía de
fútbol en donde nos encontramos
semanalmente con las mujeres niñas y
niños de mi comunidad
es tan hermoso lo que se genera en estos
momentos que no encuentro y no
encontraría palabras para poder
explicarle ese sentimiento
solo les puedo decir
que cuando estamos todas juntas nos
hacemos más fuertes
hoy ya no nos callamos más
oye hermana no tienes sin consuelo toma
mi mano aunque te invade el miedo cuando
tú creas o sientas que es el momento de
desplegar sus alas en busca de sus
sueños si en el medio de este vuelo tú
te caes tranquila es parte del proceso
como árbol de estos caldos el invierno
empieza a florecer después de un tiempo
yo quiero verte reír que sea fuerte y
feliz hey y si vos sabes de esa persona
que la está pasando mal no abandones en
buscar la forma de ayudar es un proceso
que requiere de paciencia así que arriba
a tejiendo redes y alianza para
construir caminos y plácida igualdad
[Aplausos]
i